this does tie into it in a way an
unrelated story but the underlying
sexual politics is still there this
story ahead of a local news channel a
girl's being interviewed about
coronavirus and why she doesn't wear a
mask when she's at at the park and then
out of the blue some guy walks up and
kisses her and the guy finishes kissing
her and she's got butterflies you know
she's she's like really enjoyed this
kiss and it's a funny little news story
and the news plays it all well and good
right wrong I feel as if masts are not a
hundred percent important I feel as if I
interrupted a spontaneous kiss from
someone that she doesn't know having met
just minutes earlier
Gillian McGowan says she's okay with the
kiss we asked Jack ring the man who
initiated the kiss if he's aware of all
the risks of kissing a person you don't
know during a pandemic you worry about
possibly either of you having that
passing minute oh not as I just said it
right now but yeah I probably do right
now I think is worth it
what a great story what a great amid all
this stupid political news on a great
story which is I guess these two had met
when they were walking their dog has
probably flirted a little bit then she's
being interviewed on camera and this guy
thinks it would be kind of funny and
flirtatious to walk up and while she's
on camera give her a kiss and then it's
this great moment when he pulls away she
looks like she is just floating on a
cloud she's so she's giggling about it
right a friend of mine tweeted out this
video she said a woman needs a man like
a fish needs up and then just that clip
right that's the it's the old line from
the feminist sing Gloria Steinem women
don't mean need man and then you fast
forward to this and this woman's like
gaga over this guy kissing her right so
whatever a sweet story she walks away
she goes texted me that was fun right do
you know that we now live in such a
clinical
Erol humorless culture that the news
channel that aired that segment a
segment that was so charming I thought
it was fake and staged they ended up
having to apologize because according to
this news channel what they just aired
was basically tantamount to rape a
follow up on a story that aired last
night on CTV News at 11:30 in a story on
social distancing we included an
interview with a woman in a park during
the interview a stranger came up to the
woman and kissed her directly on the
lips our story then focused on the
dangers of kissing a stranger on the
lips during a pandemic it was wrong to
air this video the video demonstrated
non-consensual behavior and downplayed
the fact that what occurred was simply
unacceptable and offensive it does not
meet CTV News editorial standards and we
apologize oh my gosh this is exactly
what we were talking about at the top of
the show this is this is exactly what
we're talking about on the racist
rapists all the kind of hysterical
claims this is what ideologue do they
have their ideas and then there's
reality and when their ideas contradict
reality the ideas have to win the ideas
have to clobber reality would anybody
look at that video would anybody look at
that interview and say that guy raped
that girl the guy who kissed the girl on
camera he raped her no least of all the
woman the woman was the one who said
text me thanks for that kiss it ties in
you know there's a statistic that goes
around college campuses that one in five
or even one in four some say women are
raped on college campus meaning that
Harvard Yard is more dangerous for women
than downtown Fallujah right that
obviously isn't true one of the places
that that number comes from is a survey
that was sent out it was conducted by
activist feminists to get ascertain what
happened in people's sexual lives and
concluded that one in five or one in
four women on college campuses have been
raped even though the women themselves
did not think that they were raped
so the women who this actually happened
to disputed the ideologue this
interpretation of their situation but
the ideologue always have to win
[Music]
[Music]